hi everybody Welcome to my second
patreon video I'm uh going to have to go
a little quick here and uh because it's
kind of loud in the building and my uh
battery continues to
die so for today I'm just going to show
you a really quick awesome thing that I
learned from Keith Marshall a long time
ago which I thought was really helpful
for me and it looks like
this okay so I'll show you one more time
just so you kind of see it
again and it's really amazing and it's
kind of what I use to get in and out of
Po juggling pretty much all the time and
so how we're going to start we're going
to break down a couple steps First
Step we're going to practice throwing
from our left hand to our right hand and
catching like this you see that I'll
show you again a little
closer why we're catching like this see
how it's kind of palm up so that we can
swing it downwards later on
so okay go ahead and practice that a
little bit catch Palm up lead with the
thumb going the other way so now we're
just going to practice practice this
next part so we're going to throw the
first one throw another one and just
catch that first one don't worry about
catching the second one so again the
first one's my orange one we're spinning
it together same in our wheel planes in
Reverse throw one throw the other you
don't worry about catching
it once we get that down a little bit
this is kind of tricky because the
timing of the second throw gets really
confusing um for me when I was first
learning so once you get that you can
move on to throw throw catch just catch
it don't worry about going into meteor
cuz I think a lot of people think we
should instantly get these tricks but if
we kind of do them a little steps feels
better and we're more successful so
throw throw catch
great more time a little closer for you
guys throw throw catch and then putting
it all together throw throw lead with
the thumb going across and a forward two
beat or three beat four beat whatever so
throw throw leading
whoa throw throw
lead okay see my thumb is now leading
the weave and just to show you this real
quick my battery does with three po I'm
juggling I'm going to throw the orange
one for my left hand when it gets back
there and here we go it's going to be
throw throw
catch I didn't do anything with this
just to kind of show you but just how
the power of that continues you can I'll
do the same thing with the orange one
here we go throw throw
catch and this is kind of the
beginning of your transitioning in and
out of three play
juggling I just want to say for my three
subscribers at this current moment and
my soon to hopefully more thanks for
watching and I really appreciate the
support and this is me and my juggle
space kind of raw and I just really
appreciate everything that um community
and my friends and family are going to
do for me thanks